I just hit you yet this is real and like
this is actually happening
no it really doesn't feel real it's like
a dream really and I'm super happy to be
here I couldn't be more thankful minutes
it's like completely this is not even
yeah not even in everybody you're around
every way imaginable how is that not
differents the real question yeah I'm so
thankful to be here like I said and when
I took on the challenge I was like yes
right away you know but then I thought
about it and I was like oh my god what
did I have to say yes to this is huge
they put on like sequins and tight pants
and a spray tan and down I'm throwing
cowboy baby rights in cowboy attic got
probably gonna get in the rhinestones
who knows something I like that I like
that have you guys don't you had a
chance to like dance yet Danner moves
around a little bit the other day
nothing too serious but those definitely
moved so we're off to a very good start
and you're working with nothing Warren
is obviously you know gonna be a great
teacher she's I keep hearing from
everyone this is like the one
so I'm super you know super happy about
that I mean a lot of people don't know
you had a pretty serious accident about
a year ago I mean it's really a miracle
that you're standing here today with us
how have you gotten past all those
challenges and struggles and gotten to
where you are here today just sheer
heart and determination you know I
wanted to come back to riding as soon as
I could
and I've done everything I can possible
to recuperate I do hot yoga I swim a run
and now this is going to be like the
first real physical test of endurance
and I think it's the perfect opportunity
for me to show that if you don't give up
on yourself you can overcome a lot
number one challenge is gonna be she
keeping up with this young lady right
here the dance moves the steps the form
but you know in bull riding
there's a lot of rhythm you have to have
timing you got to have balance and
strength so there's some comparisons
there and I'm excited to see how I can
put that into use she hadn't been too
hard on me yet but the work hasn't
really your confidence started yet I'm a
little nervous to see if she is mean as
those Bulls like I will try not to be
how do you turn a bull rider into like a
Viennese Waltz er I don't know I turned
an IndyCar driver into one last season
so hopefully I can do it for this man
[Music]